la cargaison est aussi attendu que les
premières journées chaudes du printemps
[Musique]
les drêches les céréales rejeté après la
fermentation de la bière sont mélangés
avec d'autres ingrédients
est servi aux vaches de la ferme l' aise
dans lanaudière
les animaux se régalent les drêches
évite l'enfouissement et le producteur
laitier lui quelques les économies
qu'ils réalisent il adresse et un
produit quand même compétitif qui est un
produit qui remplace un peu tous les
ingrédients que à la ferme donc ça
permet de réduire les importations à la
ferme de maïs les importations de
tourteaux soleil op les importations
d'autres sources de protéines souvent le
clip vient de l'extérieur
en plus d'être riche en protéines elle
se vante de quatre à dix fois moins cher
que le maïs ou le soya mais la majorité
des drèches des grandes brasseries
québécoises molson coors et labatt sont
écoulées aux états unis nos plus gros
clients présentement c'est des grosses
fermes laitières dans l'état du vermont
et dans l'état de new york je voudrais
que à peu près 80% à 85% de notre volume
total de ces deux ans et l'eau sont
exportés aux états unis daniel fréchette
achètent des produits alimentaires qu'il
revend au secteur agricole c'est lui qui
gère les drêches des gros joueurs chaque
semaine ils comptent entre 50 et 55
camions remorques de 35 tonnes chacun
qui traversent la frontière parce qu'on
voit s'étaler du produit qu'ils passent
un camion devant les fermes problèmes
qui pourraient les avoir ces produits
dont un constat qui désole de nombreux
producteurs bovins et laitiers les
femmes au québec on est pendant
longtemps un peu levé le nez sur les
sous-produits on est habitué avec nos
coopératives dont une ride avoir des
produits complets des muliples déjà tout
balancer fait que l'utilisation du
produit et on est dans un état sérieux
l'explosion du prix des intrants
pourrait-elle forcer un dialogue à
première vue tous le souhaite mais tout
est dans la mentalité c'est ce qu'il ya
une industrie qui est déjà présente que
je vous disais rien des réseaux munis
des réseaux sont bien établis avec des
représentants qui sont bien formés ils
sont elles qui font très bonne job mais
il ya quand même un ajustement enfin un
ajustement que la plus grande
coopérative agricole canadienne n'est
pas prête à faire pour le moment le
marché n'est pas là dit ce haut lieu au
groupe coopératif
autrefois appelée la coop fédérée qui
conseille et vend des produits aux
agriculteurs les enjeux logistique sont
trop grands dit elle pour que ce soit
une avenue économiquement intéressante
et ses mots montambault radio canada
baie-du-febvre